they must be migrating migration what a
stupid idea okay you're impossible
because I found a safe place for us to
live I want us to get out and see the
world what sort of father would I be if
I put my young F at Harm's Way for no
reason except a chance at a Caribbean
vacation I don't want to miss out on
life because you're afraid to leave this
Pond what were some of the themes about
the story uh that you co-wrote with Emmy
winner Mike White yes this is the same
guy who won an em for the White Lotus
and he co-wrote the screenplay with you
so what was that collaboration like what
were the themes that you were looking to
breakthrough and explore Chris started
talking about like very personal things
he told me he wanted to make a a love
story with ducks which I felt like was
the worst idea ever you know because
they're not the most elegant and
passionate creatures but I understood
that it was more like this sort of like
um relationship you can have with years
passing you know like after 10 years how
your relationship 10 or 20 years how
your relationship can sort of like get
more and more complicated with your
passing and you want different things
but you still love each other but you
can't make the other one happy and I
felt that was a very strong and serious
theme and I was very into it and there
was a script that I read and I I could
find this in the script so I was very
happy to to come on board and the thing
with Mike White to be very honest with
you we started working together but very
quickly he had to go on Survivor for I
mean that's his thing you know like but
uh and and I expect said that he kept
telling us I will be back in two weeks
and two months after he was actually the
finalist of Survivor so we we didn't see
him much and and and afterwards you know
like um he had to do the White Lotus so
I couldn't have a chance to work a lot
with him and Chris mandre method is very
based on you know like redoing like
rewrite and trying testing new things
and trying to to find new things so
unfortunately I didn't have a chance to
really have a close collaboration with
with Mike but I like the scripts I was
very happy to be based on that sure sure
what finally informed your approach when
it came to the look of migration
especially with h regards to the
characters and your your head of
character animation let's talk about
that I came from 2D so it was very weird
to me to approach uh 3D in the sense
that but I didn't know really the
process and one thing I I kept telling
the people I was working with that in
Tod the feeling that I had was that you
know I I start with a blank page and I
just like draw lines and it's my own way
of drawing you know like I like to be
minimalistic so I will just like do six
lines and as soon as I have what I want
to express you know I stop and I say
it's over and some call it minimalistic
some can call it lazy as well but but
you know like that's the way I love to
draw and and so again like it's starting
from nothing you add elements until you
have what you want to express and with
3D it was very weird cuz when I started
like it took maybe like two years before
I could see one picture of what the
movie could look like yeah and you're
sort of like that's it and I'm like okay
well that's it you and and and I learned
that it's more like as you're doing the
movie that you sort of adjust everything
and I didn't want to burst in the studio
at illumination and say we're going to
do what I do and like just force people
to do the same style as I did so we just
like I wanted to learn also from the
process and everything and ver process
is more like you know that you have to
Define everything very early like for
example the pond we had to Define Every
Little Rock every little leaves and we
have to you know like do the modeling of
every leaves everywhere and they showed
me that and I was freaking out at the
beginning just telling them I can't see
anything there's too much things to
watch I I can count the leaves in the
trees and I don't want that so we had to
sort like remove Elements by with the
Shadows with a light with the defocus
you know or even like making I kept
showing them like imp impressionistic
painting just saying look at how they
managed to with just one brush stroke to
to express there's a tree here and
that's making it very simple very nice
so that's sort of like the direction I
gave them and then I trusted them like
to get there and that's how we sort of
like Define step by step the look of the
film so let's talk about the casting
process I me you have a great cast K now
Johnny Elizabeth Banks Aquafina Keegan
Michael key uh how did that casting
process come about who was like the
first to sign on so to speak and have
that sort of open up the floodgates uh
the first one to come in was K
uh I think then it was Elizabeth of
course we had to find the duo first and
then think about the rest I think
afterwards the question was finding the
kids and what happened like usually
happen I think but we we had two kids
from the studio within the studio like
you know there were two people working
the project like the editor and another
director from the G Jennings and his son
was in France and he could speak English
so we had him to do Dax and we had uh
this the daughter of of um Christian
Tracy to do the the Gwen and they just
came in and do the voices which were
supposed to be scratch scratch is sort
of like temp voices and and and we
actually kept them because they were
perfect so so so that's what usually
happened and yeah and then you know like
uh it was all about like defining the
characters and finding what best actor
could find for me I I I know I was a
little bit you know with the voice
recording I was freaking out a little
bit because even in France I was used to
have someone with me um who told to the
actors because I have this problem when
I talk to actors is that I'm going to go
into this very long explanation of what
I want you know like so you have to do
this and you have to feel deep within
that you have your love for your father
but at the same time you hate him and
you have to express that in in this in
this sentence and the sentence is just
what you know like or something like
that so so it was quite complex to to
for me to work with actors and for the
first time they told me you're going to
be the one directing them by yourself
and there was of course um a scpt
screenwriter with me to help me you know
at at the beginning Mike was here to
sort of like guide me to uh and then it
was other writers as as he left and um
but still it was very very scary and um
and even some sometimes I have to be
honest like when they started like
speaking way too fast I couldn't
understand what was happening and they
started like laughing all of them the
whole room was laughing and I that's how
I learned to laugh as well and so great
but but uh yeah no but other than this
yeah it was a pleasure and I was very
you know like erard also
by the fact that they were you know like
I'm this French little guy and they were
really professional with me like trying
to really get what I was trying to
express and everything and was really a
great experience what time of the year
what year did you actually record the
voiceovers for five years for the whole
production we recorded like I would say
like every three months or something
like that like because we had to change
the script regularly so so it actually
lasted for three or four years I think
that means you were actually making this
movie during the peak yeah the the the
hardest most difficult time during like
Co and the pandemic we had to record
actors in their home you know we had to
bring the little studio in their home so
they could sort of like record
themselves and and kumel had this sort
of like little plastic shower where he
had to go in and and he had to do the
levels by himself you know when when he
was yelling we had to are you sure
you're good in terms of pecking so that
was quite complic complicated but yeah I
mean we we managed to do it so that's
really when comes to animated movies
sometimes people don't really think
enough you know outside people not
making the movie don't think like oh
there's a cinematographer you have a
production designer so how did your
collaboration with them help you know
help you direct and help Define the
various looks of migration well it was
um I think the the biggest challenge was
to find how do you perceive the World
Through The Eyes of ducks you know like
for example New York we really worked on
it like even the way they arve in New
York York we felt okay we need to make
sure we're surprised by discovering the
city and so we decided to sort of like
hide it in the fog and and and make it a
scene when they arrive that's more
feeling like like you know like ulis in
the Odus you know like on the ocean with
fog everywhere and there's big giant
rocks next to him and you don't know
what it is it could be an island as much
as it could be like a monstrous like sea
monster that you know it's really a
movie about like getting out of your
comfort zone and being rewarded for that
you actually did research and prep tell
us about yeah we had a duck at the
studio who came one day like uh it was
really weird like the duck came and and
uh he was in a little box and there was
like maybe 50 to 60 people like just
because we're working in a parking lot I
mean not in in the parking lot but you
know like it's a parking lot that's been
like re rebuilt to and and there's part
that's still a parking lot so we were
all like 50 people and the guy opened
the box and the duck stepped out and and
no one was talking we were just watching
the duck you know like doing his things
it was not much but he was just walking
and looking at us and I don't know it
must have felt for him like what a human
must feel when he's abducted by aliens
you know like people are just writing
down things with him like moving and and
he just there was a little you know like
part of water he just went in and washed
and watching us and that's it so that
was interesting but he was not armed
everything was good you know like he he
was a but yeah we did a lot of studies
of course videos also we we watch a lot
of videos and and the good thing with
maras is that they're literally
everywhere so it's very easy to to go
you know like do documentation and it
gives you like permission to go on a
walk to just see oh I'm going to work
and watch ducks and that's all you're
doing so so that was very and also
learning about their habits and
everything it was very interesting uh
prior to this movie everything I knew
about ducks I learned from watching
friends you know the chick and the duck
uh but yes I definitely my uh my my
education was expanded in a big way also
uh you know this last question is um you
know you talk about breaking out of your
comfort zone and the rewards that come
from that also the risks that come from
that too and I mean look and I grew up
in Philly in New York and I moved out
here 30 years ago and and the reward is
I've been very very happy in LA but what
do you hope people take other than being
very entertained with great music and
beautiful animation and funny you know a
lot of humor what do you what are some
of the themes that you hope people take
away from migration well I I guess it's
mostly this idea of you know like again
what I just shared with you with this
idea of okay you step out and maybe you
will will be rewarded and maybe you
won't but that's definitely the only way
you can sort of evolve and and I know I
have this problem of you know like
staying home and running in circle
because it's comfortable because you
know you're you're the king of your
little home and and everything and and
yeah it's worth it it's going to be hard
but it's definitely worth it and it's
how you're going to live things and and
that's what we wanted to share with this
with with this movie so that's the the
idea that we had you know making it I
don't know if we succeeded but at least
we tried our best you know like to get
to this feeling so that's uh that was
our our you know main sort of like uh
goal for for making this movie yeah well
I think you succeeded do you think you
succeeded absolutely so ladies and
gentlemen just uh please spr the word
that migration opens in US theaters on
December 22nd Benjamin rener thank you
so much for the conversation thank you
everyone for being here at the Academy
thank you so
much
that